[Musique]
ce mercredi 19 avril les élus du conseil
départemental se sont retrouvés dans
l'hémicycle du Palais de la source pour
une commission permanente un peu
spéciale avant d’aborder les dossiers
prévus à l'ordre du jour le président du
Département Cyril Melchior a reçu une
femme qui s'est distinguée par son
courage et sa détermination dans la
lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales Thérèse Baillif c'est en
hommage à son engagement en faveur du
droit des femmes que la collectivité a
annoncé ce matin la création d'une
nouvelle distinction le prix Thérèse
Baif vous avez des personnes qui
s'engagent au quotidien bénévolement
poils lutter contre ces violences à ta
famille
simplicités et humilité
une femme engagée simplement mais avec
détermination
c'est pour cela que nous créons un prix
Thérèse Baïf qui va valoriser
l'engagement des femmes au service des
autres notamment contre les violences
intra-familiales avec ce prix Thérèse
Baïf devient un symbole de l'engagement
au féminin une nouvelle qui remplit
d'émotions ce ressenti c'est une immense
gratitude envers le département et
surtout le président du département pour
être toujours aussi conscient de de la
problématique des violences des
violences intrafondiales aussi
départements et que je sois aujourd'hui
devenu un petit peu le symbole de cette
lutte qui continue je dis merci vraiment
je me sens extrêmement honoré bien sûr
et très ému j'ai souvent
retenu un petit peu
mes larmes un peu parce que c'est très
c'est très émouvant quelque chose comme
ça et merci le président et le
département de m'avoir distingué pour ce
prix le prix Thérèse Bailly récompensera
chaque année l'action citoyenne d'une
femme réunionnaise il sera remis le 8
mars lors de la journée internationale
des droits des femmes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]